[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen auf unserem planeten sich
kennenlernen
sie lernen sich kennen
sie haben
ich kennen gelernt
keine angst ich bin auf dem weg retten
der superheld rettet die frau der
superheld hat die frau gerettet
[Musik]
stehlen
sie spielt das handy
[Musik]
sie hat das handy gestohlen springen
er springt ins wasser er ist ins wasser
gesprungen
schießen sie schießt ein tor
sie hat ein tor geschossen schießen
er schießt den ball er hat den ball
geschossen springen sich bringt in den
see sie ist in den see gesprungen
stehlen
er stiehlt das handy er hat das handy
gestohlen retten
sie rettet den verletzten sie hat den
verletzten gerettet
sich kennenlernen wir lernen uns kennen
wir haben uns kennengelernt